David Boder: [In English] This is Spool number 24, taken the 4th of August, 1946, at 9 Rue de Patin, Paris. The interviewee is Mrs. Bertha Goldwasser, née Rosenstrauch, age 34. She is here in Paris and works with the Neue Freie Presse, a Jewish newspaper.
David Boder: [In German] Also Frau Goldwasser, wollen Sie uns wieder geben Ihren vollen Namen und wer Sie sind.
Bertha Goldwasser: Mein Name ist Goldwasser. Geboren in Polen, verheiratet hab ich in Paris. Mein Mann, sein Name war Kuba Goldwasser, der...welcher war deportiert im 41. Jahr und arretiert bei der deutschen Gestapo.
David Boder: In Paris?
Bertha Goldwasser: In Paris.
David Boder: Also sagen Sie mal, Frau Goldwasser, wo waren Sie, wenn der Krieg hat angefangen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Wenn der Krieg hat angefangen war ich hier in Paris die ganze Zeit bis im Jahr, bis im Jahr 41. An dem Tag, wo man hat meinen Mann arretiert...und von der Deportation habe ich nichts gewusst. Vierzehn Tage später hat man mich auch arretiert mit meinem neun monatigen Mädchen.
David Boder: Bitte etwas näher, ein bisschen [unverständlich], ja? Man hat Sie also arretiert mit ihrem neun Monate alten Kind?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Erzählen Sie mir, wie es da war. Sie lebten mit ihrem Mann in Paris, nicht wahr?
David Boder: Was war seine Beschäftigung?
Bertha Goldwasser: Seine Beschäftigung war, er war Ingenieur.
David Boder: Er war ein Ingenieur.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ingenieur, ja.
David Boder: Und haben Sie noch andere Kinder?
Bertha Goldwasser: Nein.
David Boder: Das war Ihr...
Bertha Goldwasser: Mein Einziges, mein einziges Baby...
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . ich habe gehabt.
David Boder: Haben Sie das Kind noch mit?
Bertha Goldwasser: Nein. Ich bin auch deportiert und, hm,nun ich habe gewusst schon wo die Deportation hingeht und bin ich vom Zug hier runter gesprungen mit meinem Kind auf dem Arm. Und leider Gottes hat mein Kind den Tod erfahren während ich bin herunter gesprungen. Und ich selber war auch schwer verwundet, aber die Franzosen habe mich aufgehoben und mich...in neun Monaten auskuriert. Und nachher...
David Boder: Welche Franzosen? Die, die auf dem Zug waren?
Bertha Goldwasser: Nein, die waren auf dem Boden. Die Franzosen, die haben gewohnt bei dem...
David Boder: Nicht so schnell, bitte. Also Ihr Mann würde...wurde arretiert und was hat man mit ihm gemacht?
Bertha Goldwasser: Man hat ihn deportiert nach Deutschland, um im Salzgraben zu arbeiten.
David Boder: Ja. Wie hat man ihn arretiert? Erzählen Sie mir die Einzelheiten von diesem Fall.
Bertha Goldwasser: Mich hat man zu Hause...
David Boder: Nein, nein—Ihren Mann.
Bertha Goldwasser: Meinen Mann hat man auch zu Hause arretiert, es war am...am 26 August...
David Boder: August.
Bertha Goldwasser: August um neun Uhr früh sind die Gestapo zu Hause hinein gekommen und haben gefragt seinem Namen.
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Und dann haben Sie gesagt: „Ah, sie sind Jude! Dann kommen Sie. Sie gut für, für Arbeit in Deutschland.” Mein Mann hat gearbeitet, hm, geantwortet: „Arbeiten ist bei mir kein Schreck, aber ich möchte nicht das durchmachen, was meine Freund schon haben mitgemacht in Deutschland.” Dann haben sie ihn beim Rücken genommen und die Stiegen herunter geschmissen. Und sie sagen: „Wir werden dir schon Arbeit geben, du wirst lange arbeiten für uns.” Und nachher ist er...haben sie ihn nach Deutschland deportiert. Sie haben ihn weggenommen von Drancy und von dort haben sie ihn nach Pantin geschickt.
David Boder: Und wer hat Ihnen das gesagt? Hat er Ihnen geschrieben?
Bertha Goldwasser: Das, darüber habe ich von den Deutschen selber ein Papier bekommen, dass der Jude, der Häftlings-Jude Goldwasser fahrt nach Deutschland as freiwilliger Arbeiter.
David Boder: Als Freiwilliger?
Bertha Goldwasser: Als freiwilliger Arbeiter. Aber das ist nicht wahr, denn sie haben es mit allen Juden und auch Franzosen gemacht. Aber das waren keine Freiwilligen, weil kein Jude und kein Franzose hat für die Deutschen sich freiwillig gemeldet.
David Boder: Erzählen Sie mir, Frau Goldwasser, wann hat man Ihnen dieses Papier gegeben?
Bertha Goldwasser: Das Papier habe ich bekommen, hab ich bekommen in, hm,...April, am 11 April.
David Boder: Und sie haben ihn im August genommen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, im 41 Jahr.
David Boder: Ja und...
Bertha Goldwasser: Am 11 April...
David Boder: Am elften 11 April...
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . im 42. Jahr habe ich das...
David Boder: . . . das Papier bekommen.
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . das Papier bekommen.
David Boder: Was hat man...hat man es Ihnen zu geschickt oder haben sie es gegeben?
Bertha Goldwasser: Mit der Post.
David Boder: Man hat Sie mit der Post verständigt?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Dass er freiwillig nach Deutschland gegangen ist zu arbeiten.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja. Und auch unten haben sie dazu geschrieben: der Häftlings-Jude.
David Boder: Ja. Und nun also dann ist ihr Mann weggegangen und sie sind mit dem Kind geblieben.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ah hm, ich bin mit dem Kind geblieben.
David Boder: Und wann hat man Sie arretiert?
Bertha Goldwasser: Am sechzehnten Juli im 42 Jahr.
David Boder: Das war ungefähr ein Jahr später.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, ein Jahr später.
David Boder: Na, warten Sie mal, war das Kind schon geboren wie Ihr Mann weg ging?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, das Kind war schon geboren.
David Boder: Das Kind war schon geboren, wenn Ihr Mann weg ging?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, wie mein Mann weg gegangen ist.
David Boder: Und das Kind war dann neun Monate alt?
Bertha Goldwasser: Neun...es war neun Monate alt.
David Boder: Und wie man Sie arretiert hat, war das Kind schon ungefähr ein ein halb Jahre alt oder so, nicht wahr?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja. Nein, es war so, wenn neun Monate, das Kind hat neun Monate gehabt, da bin ich schon einmal arretiert worden...
David Boder: Ja?
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . wenn ich bin zum Lager gegangen, um mein Mann...meinem Mann Brot herein geworfen haben.
David Boder: Oh, was nun?
Bertha Goldwasser: Da hat man mich arretiert das erste Mal mit dem Kind zusammen. Ich habe das Kind mitgenommen. Ich habe geglaubt, wenn sie ein Kind sehen, lassen sie mich im Lager durch gehen.
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Aber das hat nicht geholfen und wie die Anderen bin ich auch arretiert worden.
David Boder: War das in Paris?
Bertha Goldwasser: In Drancy.
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ein paar Kilometer von Paris, zwei...
Bertha Goldwasser: Nicht weit.
David Boder: So und dann...wie hat man Sie weg gelassen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Man hat mich nach Drancy reingenommen auch...
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . aber mein Mann hat von dem gar nicht gewusst.
Bertha Goldwasser: Dann hat man...dann haben die Franzosen eingewendet, dass ich...
David Boder: Welche Franzosen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Die Franzo, französischen...die, der Kommandant von dem französischen Lager.
David Boder: Ja?
Bertha Goldwasser: Der französische Kommandant von dem Lager...
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . hat eingewendet, ich soll mit dem Kind hinaus lassen.
Bertha Goldwasser: Hat mich hinaus...nachher und nachher die Polizei...
David Boder: Und warum hat er das getan?
Bertha Goldwasser: Er hat Mitleid gehabt...mit dem Kind wahrscheinlich. Und er hat nicht gekonnt es anders machen, weil ich die erste Frau war, die arretiert war zu der Zeit.
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Ja und nun hat man Sie...sprechen Sie in diese Richtung. So hat man Sie entlassen und Sie sind nach Hause gekommen.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich bin nach Hause gekommen.
David Boder: Wo haben Sie da gewohnt?
Bertha Goldwasser: Nicht mehr auf der Strasse...ich war nicht mehr, nicht weit...auf einer Anderen, auf einer ganz Anderen [unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich hab...
David Boder: Haben Sie eine Armband tragen müssen? Haben Sie eine Schleife tragen müssen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich habe müssen tragen einen Magen David, wie man sagt, und darauf geschrieben...
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . mit „Juive”.
Bertha Goldwasser: Aber ich habe es nicht getragen, weil niemand mir erkennt, dass ich eine Jüdin bin...
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . hab ich mir erlaubt, es nicht zu tragen.
David Boder: Sie haben das riskiert, nicht wahr?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich habe es riskiert, ja!
David Boder: Ja. Nun und so sind Sie nach Hause gekommen mit dem Kind.
Bertha Goldwasser: Und so bin ich nach Hause gekommen mit dem Kind.
David Boder: Nun—und was haben Sie dann getan? Haben Sie gearbeitet?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich habe vor gehabt zu arbeiten...
David Boder: Wo?
Bertha Goldwasser: Illegal bei Schneiderei.
David Boder: Bei Schneiderei. Können Sie nähen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich kann nähen auch, ja.
David Boder: Ja. Und wie lange haben Sie gearbeitet und wo haben Sie gearbeitet...bis, hm, man Sie wieder arretiert hat?
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . bis ich wieder arretiert...
David Boder: Erzählen Sie mir die Einzelheiten von diesem Arrest.
Bertha Goldwasser: Man hat mich...um vier Uhr in der Früh sind sie gekommen zu mir nach Hause und man hat geklopft...
David Boder: Um vier...
Bertha Goldwasser: Uhr in der Früh hat man geklopft—hab ich nicht geantwortet.
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Dann noch einmal und dann...haben sie die Tür eingebrochen.
Bertha Goldwasser: Aber ich hab gehabt ein Fenster, was hat gegehen auf...hm, auf ein Dach von einem anderen Haus. So bin ich von dem Fenster hinaus und hab angefangen...
David Boder: Sagen Sie, waren Sie angekleidet?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich hab mich angekleidet...nur ein Peignoir [= Morgenmantel] hab ich mir mitgenommen...
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . und ich bin durch das Fenster hinaus und ich hab angefangen auf [unverständlich] zu gehen.
David Boder: Ja?
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . bis ich nicht mehr...und sie haben angefangen mir nach zu schießen. Und dann habe ich mir unter gegeben.
David Boder: Mit dem Kind?
Bertha Goldwasser: Dann bin ich runter gekommen und da haben sie schon das Kind gehabt. Weil die ganze Zeit seit dem ersten Arretierung habe ich das Kind nicht bei mir gehabt. Meine Hausfrau hat das Kind gehalten.
David Boder: Ihre Hausfrau hat das...?
Bertha Goldwasser: Hat das Kind gehalten.
David Boder: Ja?
Bertha Goldwasser: Und nachher, wie ich bin runter gekommen, haben sie schon das Kind gehabt und haben mich, so wie ich bin gestanden, haben sie mich in das Lager genommen.
David Boder: Und sie haben Ihnen das Kind gegeben?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, sie haben das Kind mir gegeben, ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Das war ein großes Lager, wo hundert...hunderte, tausende von Frauen und Kinder und auch Männer waren, so zusammen gruppiert.
David Boder: Alles Juden?
Bertha Goldwasser: Alles Juden, nur Juden. Und nachher haben sie angefangen auszusortieren, aussortieren wie man sagt, und die Frauen mit Kindern nach Drancy gebracht.
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Und von dort wurden die Kinder in den Zug genommen und anders deportiert, man genommen die Kinder und deportiert besonders.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich hab mich...aber ich hab mich...[pause]
David Boder: Sie sind vom Zug heraus gesprungen.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich hab mir gedacht...ich habe gebeten dort die Frau, die deutsche Frau...die hat mich gern gehabt, weil sie selber verheiratet war mit einem Juden. Und sie war da...sie war in Frankreich und sie hat mich von zuvor gekannt auch. Dann hat sie gesagt...
David Boder: Sie hat Sie gekannt? War es eine Bekannte von Paris?
Bertha Goldwasser: Es war eine Bekannte von Paris, die was hat da bei mir gewohnt. Aber sie hat wollen sich retten und sie hat gesagt, dass sie eine Deutsche ist, aber sie war eine Österreicherin, eine Wienerin war...
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . und auch ein Jüd, ein Mischling,...
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . und sie...sie hat mir gesagt, ich soll hinein gehen in den zweiten Wagon, dort sind die Kinder und ich soll sagen, sie hat mich geschickt. Und dann bin ich in den zweiten Wagon hinein und ich habe...und ich habe dort mein Kind gefunden. Und so sind wir [unverständlich] und es waren andere Mütter auch, die—ich weiß nicht auf welche Art wie...wie die zu die Kinder kommen. Und wie wir sind gekommen bei Colmar bei der Grenze...bei Colmar...sind wir, bin ich vom Zug hinaus gesprungen.
David Boder: Nun warten Sie mal, was für Wagon waren das?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ein versiegelter Wagon, ein ganz vermachter Wagon für...für...
David Boder: Ein Liefer-Wagon?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ein Wagon für die...für die Viecher, wie man, wie man...
David Boder: Für Vieh?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Ein Vieh-Wagon.
David Boder: Nun und wie konnte Sie raus springen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Es waren...da waren drei...les planches, wie sagt man da?
David Boder: Die Bretter waren nicht fest...?
Bertha Goldwasser: Die Bretter waren apart...und so...
David Boder: Oh, das war ein richtiger Vieh-Wagon?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Denn so hat man das Vieh transportiert...
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, das Vieh...
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Und dann haben die [unverständlich]...habe ich einen—ich weiß, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wo ich die Kraft her dazu genommen, ich hab ausgebrochen einen Breiten und ich hab gesehen der Zug fängt an den Berg hinauf zu gehen...
David Boder: Ja?
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . bin ich hinunter gesprungen mit dem Kind.
David Boder: Hat Ihnen jemand das erzählt, dass es besser zu springen ist, wenn der Zug bergauf geht?
Bertha Goldwasser: Nein, nein, ich habe mich schon mit dem Gedanken die ganze Zeit ge...getragen. Ich hab mir gesagt: „Einmal und für alles zum Tode fahr ich doch und da kann ich doch vielleicht mir das Leben zu retten.”
David Boder: Ja?
Bertha Goldwasser: Und dem Kind. Aber leider habe ich das Kind verloren beim Runterspringen. Und mit die Hände...mit meine Hände habe ich müssen das Kind zusammen nehmen...extra Teile von dem Körper habe ich im Wald gelassen.
David Boder: Was heißt extra Teile von...?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ein Fuß, eine Hand habe ich...
David Boder: Gesucht zusammen...?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, wenn ich bin herunter gesprungen der Zug ist schnell den Berg...den Berg hinauf gegangen...
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . und so kann ich mich selber nicht kann vor...nach vorn gehen. Und dann sind gekommen zwei französische Männer—von der Arbeit sind sie gekommen und haben sie mich gefragt, was ich hier mache. Und ich habe gesagt, ich bin eine Christin und die Deutschen habe mich bis hierher gebracht und haben mich da gelassen. Ich habe mich nicht getraut ihnen die Wahrheit zu sagen.
David Boder: Sie haben ihnen nicht gesagt, dass sie vom Zug gesprungen...
Bertha Goldwasser: Nein.
David Boder: Nein.
Bertha Goldwasser: Hab mich nicht getraut...
David Boder: Und war der Körper des Kindes noch mit Ihnen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Nein, sie haben schon nichts gesehen von dem Kind.
David Boder: Sie haben das Kind begraben?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich habe sie begraben, ja. Und dann kommen die Leute und sie haben mich mit sich genommen und haben mich, hm,...die Wunden gewaschen und ich bin geblieben...
David Boder: Wo waren Sie verwundet?
Bertha Goldwasser: Das Knie, habe ich jetzt zwei [unverständlich] gebrochen gehabt.
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Im linken Fuß, ja. Und auch den ganzen Rücken hab ich zerschlagen gehabt, ich hab überhaupt—ich kann nicht gehen, ich kann nicht liegen und kein Essen hat dann geschmeckt. Aber ich war doch mit die Leute, die waren sehr nett zu mir und die haben mich auskuriert.
David Boder: Haben sie einen Doktor gebracht?
Bertha Goldwasser: Nein, ich habe nicht gewollt, ich habe gesagt, ich...
David Boder: Aber wie kann man einen gebrochenen Fuß auskurieren?
Bertha Goldwasser: Da war ein...ein Geistlicher, der hat mir das gemacht.
David Boder: Ein Geistlicher?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ein Geistlicher.
David Boder: Der hat Ihnen den Fuß verbunden?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, verbunden. Und so bin ich geblieben neun [9] Monate mit diese Leute.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mal, wenn man mit einem Geistliche zusammen kommt, hat der nicht verstehen können, dass Sie Jüdin waren?
Bertha Goldwasser: Aber die Geistlichen selber haben sehr viel für die Juden getan.
David Boder: Die Geistlichen?
Bertha Goldwasser: die französischen Geistlichen haben schon sehr viel für die Juden getan. Sie haben hunderte Kinder auf ge...aufgehalten mit sich.
David Boder: Ja?
Bertha Goldwasser: Sehr viel—die Geistlichen und auch die, hm, nun Schwestern.
Bertha Goldwasser: Sie haben sehr viele Kinder bei hier in Frankreich auch auf...
David Boder: Das ist wirklich wahr?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ganz wahr, so wie ich sage.
David Boder: Ja, ich meine, dass man das erzählt hat in Amerika und wir wissen, wir haben gehört, dass die französischen Geistlichen gut waren, besonders gut.
Bertha Goldwasser: Sehr gut.
David Boder: Ja. So?
Bertha Goldwasser: Und nachher—da hat der Geistliche mit mir zu reden angefangen. Und ich habe gesehen, ich kann zu ihm Zutrauen haben, weil ich habe ihn einmal gefragt, was ist eigentlich an der Front [unverständlich—Rauschen im Tonband]. Und die Leute mit denen ich war, gehörten auch zur französischen Resistance.
David Boder: Und die Leute haben auf Sie [unverständlich; starkes Rauschen im Tonband] und sie sind gesund geworden. Und wohin sind Sie dann gegangen?
Bertha Goldwasser: [unverständlich; starkes Rauschen im Tonband]...und so bis zur Befreiung war ich bei der französischen Resistance und habe gearbeitet dort bis zur Befreiung.
David Boder: Nun erzählen Sie mir etwas von der Arbeit der französischen Resistance.
Bertha Goldwasser: Die französische Resistance hat sehr viel gearbeitet und hat, hat viel für die Juden getan. Wenn wir, wenn sie gehört haben, dass Juden arretiert wurden, haben sie gleich geschickt und die Juden in die Wälder genommen. Sie waren organisiert militärisch und wir haben sehr viel gegen die Deutschen gemacht
David Boder: Was haben sie, zum Beispiel, gemacht?
Bertha Goldwasser: [unverständlich; starkes Rauschen im Tonband] gegen das deutsche Militär. Wir haben gegen das Militär Granaten geworfen und danach haben sie gestört im Vormarsch.
David Boder: Sie haben was verhindert?
Bertha Goldwasser: Im Vormarsch. Wir haben auch Flieger gehabt, [unverständlich; starkes Rauschen im Tonband] Amerikaner, Kanadier und Englische, die haben herunter geschossen und die herunter geschossen sind. Die Flugzeuge wurden herunter geschossen. Diese Leute, die Amerikaner, diese „avaiteur”, wenn sie waren krank oder [unverständlich; starkes Rauschen im Tonband], wir haben sie zur der spanischen als auch der schweizerischen Grenze gebracht. Ich selber hab vier und zwanzig kanadische „avaiateuren” Flieger zu der spanischen Grenze geführt. Und dort habe ich sie übergeben der schweizerischen Resistance und auch an Geistliche. Diese haben ihnen angezogen andere Kleider und haben sie nach Spanien geführt.
David Boder: Aha. Und in Spanien hat man was? Hat man sie interniert oder?
Bertha Goldwasser: In Spanien sind sie gleich angewendet an die amerikanische Konsulat und die sind weiter nach Marokko oder nach London heim gefahren.
David Boder: Und Sie sagen, Sie haben selbst mit diesen englischen oder kanadischen Soldaten gearbeitet.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, habe ich.
David Boder: In welcher Stadt war das?
Bertha Goldwasser: Es war, hm, in [Name unverständlich—klingt wie Parie de Mont Jacques] und von da bin ich mit vier und zwanzig Personen nach Toulouse gegangen. Da sind die Geistlichen gekommen und habe die Leute uebernommen von mir.
David Boder: So die Geistlichen waren mit der Resistance?
Bertha Goldwasser: Mit der Resistance, sehr viel von die Geistlichen.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, hm, was...wo haben Sie...hm, wo waren Sie wie die Befreiung gekommen ist?
Bertha Goldwasser: Wenn die Befreiung gekommen ist, war ich in Paris. Ich war auch—ich bin gewesen als Leutnant, als Leutnant von der FFI, von der Resistance.
David Boder: Ja?
Bertha Goldwasser: Und ich...ich war das zweite Mal verwundet in Paris.
David Boder: Wieso?
Bertha Goldwasser: Weil ich hab müssen durch gehen, wo die Deutschen haben abgezogen—so schnell, so schnell man kann sich das gar nicht vorstellen. Und ich hab wollen durchgehen auf die zweite Seite und verständigen meine, meine Kameraden, dass sie erst [unverständlich; starkes Rauschen im Tonband] die Deutschen. Und die haben das bemerkt und haben geschossen. Ich war verwundet im Fuß und ich war zwölf Monat—zwölf Wochen war ich im Gips mit dem Fuß. Aber nachher...war ich sehr schnell auskuriert und auch meine Moral bei mir war ganz anders. Und auch bis zum heutigen Tag, dass ich arbeit für den militärischen Staff, das heißt in der Resistance der FFI [unverständlich; starkes Rauschen im Tonband].
David Boder: Oh, die Resistance existiert noch? Die ist nicht hier auf...
Bertha Goldwasser: Sie existiert noch bis jetzt.
David Boder: Ja. Bitte weiter.
Bertha Goldwasser: Weil sie findet vom Militär statt.
David Boder: Und Sie sind ein Mitglied der Resistance?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich bin ein Mitglied der Resistance, FFI, mit dem Kontingent der Marseillaise.
David Boder: Also, was tun Sie jetzt im Militär stehen Sie?
Bertha Goldwasser: Jetzt haben Sie mich demobilisiert, weil ich schon zu alt bin [lacht] für den Militärdienst [lacht].
David Boder: Oh, Sie sind vier und dreißig Jahre, Sie sehen aber aus wie acht und zwanzig.
Bertha Goldwasser: Aber für das Militär...
David Boder: Wenn Sie zu alt sind, wen haben sie dann in der Resistance, fünfzehn jährige Kinder?
Bertha Goldwasser: Nein, bis sieben, acht und zwanzig sind die Frauen. Weil die jetzigen Frauen der Resistance fahren nach Marokko. Ich hab nicht wollen nach Marokko fahren, weil ich hab suchen wollen meinen Bruder, den man hat gefunden im Lager von Föhrenwald bei München.
David Boder: Na, warten Sie mal—Sie hatten einen Bruder?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Wo hat er gelebt, wenn...wenn der Krieg anfing?
Bertha Goldwasser: In Polen war er bis zum 40 Jahr und dann...
David Boder: Haben Sie mit Ihrer Familie in Polen korrespondiert?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich habe einen letzten Brief...ich hab den letzten Brief von meiner Mutter bekommen in 42, im Mai...im Mai.
David Boder: Wann sind Sie denn von Polen weggegangen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Im sechs und dreißigsten 36 Jahr, am zwanzigsten Juni.
David Boder: Wieso sind Sie weg gegangen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich kam hierher zum Lernen.
David Boder: Nach Paris?
Bertha Goldwasser: Nach Paris.
David Boder: Was wollten Sie erlernen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich hab wollen...ich habe wollen lernen Chemie Ingenieur.
David Boder: Sie wollten Chemie studieren?
Bertha Goldwasser: Chemie studieren.
David Boder: Wo haben Sie das Gymnasium beendet?
Bertha Goldwasser: In Polen, in Baracz, da habe ich die Matura gemacht.
David Boder: Da haben Sie die Matura gemacht.
Bertha Goldwasser: Matura.
David Boder: Und dann sind Sie gekommen nach hier um chemische Ingenieur zu studieren, wo?
Bertha Goldwasser: In Paris.
David Boder: An welcher Schule?
Bertha Goldwasser: An der Faculte de...[unverständlich].
David Boder: Haben Sie dort angefangen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich hab angefangen...ich hab mich verschreiben, aber ich hab nicht angefangen. Meine Mutter war nicht so reich, dass sie mich aufhaltet. Und ich selber—die Sprache hab ich nicht gekannt und ich kann nur soweit vor gehen.
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Dann habe ich angefangen „lessons” zu geben, lernen polnisch, und dann habe ich auch französisch gelernt.
David Boder: Wer wollte jetzt polnisch lernen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Es waren...waren Kolonien von polnische Arbeiter, die in den Kohlengruben gearbeitet haben.
David Boder: Hier?
Bertha Goldwasser: Hier in Frankreich
David Boder: Und die wollten polnisch lernen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, die haben da ja Kinder und [unverständlich] und Kinder, die waren das.
David Boder: Aha, und in diesen Kolonien wollten sie, dass die Kinder polnisch lernen.
Bertha Goldwasser: Natürlich, ja, das waren doch Polen.
David Boder: Ja. Und wann waren sie verheiratet?
Bertha Goldwasser: Im acht und dreißigsten 38 Jahr.
David Boder: Hier in...
Bertha Goldwasser: Hier in Paris.
David Boder: Hier in Paris.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, und dann kamen Sie...und Sie hatten, hm,...wie gross war Ihre Familie in Polen?
Bertha Goldwasser: In Polen habe ich mein...meine Mutter und meinen Bruder gehabt.
David Boder: Und der Vater?
Bertha Goldwasser: Mein Vater ist schon lange gestorben; ich war ein Kind mit vier Jahr.
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Meinen Bruder habe ich verlassen, da war er fünfzehn Jahre alt. Ich habe auch Onkel und Tanten von meiner Mutter und Neffen von meiner Mutter Bruder und Schwägerin mit die Kinder.
Bertha Goldwasser: Aber in Amerika habe ich zwei Tanten.
David Boder: Zwei Tanten?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Also wollen wir erst mit den polnischen Verwandten, also wann haben Sie zuletzt von Ihrer Mutter gehört?
Bertha Goldwasser: Von meiner Mutter habe ich im 42 Jahre gehört. Im Mai habe ich den letzten Brief von ihr bekommen.
David Boder: Wo war sie denn?
Bertha Goldwasser: Sie war in Baracz—zu Hause.
David Boder: Ja. Und was, hm,...wie ist es Ihrer Mutter gegangen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Meine Mutter, meiner Mutter ist es—bevor der Krieg—ganz gut gegangen, aber wie die alle sie haben alles weggenommen da, haben sie aus dem Haus raus geschmissen und sie in ein Ghetto gesteckt, sowie alle anderen Juden. Und dort wahrscheinlich waren sie sehr schlecht behandelt, geschlagen und die Alten sind in die Gaskammern gegangen. Das haben sie mir erzählt. Und die Gaskammern waren sie erstickt.
David Boder: Aber was hat Ihrer Mutter passiert?
Bertha Goldwasser: Mein Mutter hat man nach Treblinka genommen in ein...
David Boder: Treblinka?
Bertha Goldwasser: Treblinka, in ein Lager gebracht. Und dort wurde sie in die Gaskammer [unverständlich].
David Boder: Wer hat Ihnen das erzählt?
Bertha Goldwasser: Das hat mir mein Bruder erzählt. Der war...er war bei den Russen eingezogen, das war in Polen. Nachher, wie die Russen sich zurück gezogen haben, ist er mit nach Russland. Und dort ist er zur Armee, der Russischen und er...er ist Soldat. Er war drei mal verwundet. Er hat gekämpft an der ost preußischen Grenze unter dem Kommando von einem jüdischen General.
David Boder: Und wer war das?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ein...
David Boder: War das der General, der gefallen ist.
Bertha Goldwasser: Der gefallen ist.
David Boder: Yurenko?
Bertha Goldwasser: Yur—...nein, nicht Yurenko.
David Boder: Ja, in Nordost Preußen.
Bertha Goldwasser: In Nordost Preußen.
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Er war verwundet und man hat ihn nach Moskau gebracht und ihn auskuriert. Nachher ging es ihm ganz gut in Russland. Das hat er mir geschrieben. Aber dann hat er sich gedenkt, dass er da ganz alleine ist. Er ist ja noch ein Kind. Und er hat gesehen vielleicht, dass er findet die Mutter. So ging er nach Hause, nach Polen, nach Baracz und er hat die Mutter nicht gefunden, keinen Menschen. So ist er weiter nach Polen...und in Polen hat er keinen von der Familie vorgefunden. So ist er nach Deutschland gekommen. In Deutschland hat er auch niemanden erfahren. Dann ist er weiter bis nach München und...und hat sich angeschlossen in dem Lager von der UNRRA. Dort hat er sich registriert für Amerika oder nach Palästina zu fahren. Aber wenn er hat von meiner Tante von Amerika bekommen hat meine Adresse und auch mich hat verständigt auf meiner Adresse in Frankreich geschrieben und jetzt bin ich in Kontakt mit ihm.
David Boder: Wo ist der Bruder?.
Bertha Goldwasser: Mein Bruder ist in Mün...bei München—im Föhrenwald im Lager.
David Boder: In einem Lager—und er korrespondiert mit Ihnen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Warum kommt er nicht nach Paris?
Bertha Goldwasser: Weil ich selber weiß nicht was zu machen in Paris. Vielleicht er...
David Boder: Wie alt ist er?
Bertha Goldwasser: Er ist jetzt vier und zwanzig Jahre alt, im fünf und zwanzigsten fast jetzt.
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Also ich selber weiß nicht was zu machen,...ihn nach Paris zu nehmen? Ich bin allein. Ich vielleicht kann ihm eine Zukunft schaffen...und in Amerika, die Tanten wollen ihn nach Amerika haben.
David Boder: Die Tanten wollen ihn in Amerika?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, die haben ihm ein Affidavit geschickt.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mal, wo leben Ihre Tanten?
Bertha Goldwasser: Meine Tante lebt in Brooklyn.
David Boder: In Brooklyn near New York?
Bertha Goldwasser: New York.
David Boder: Und wie heißen die?
Bertha Goldwasser: Rosa Drah.
David Boder: Rosa...
Bertha Goldwasser: Rosa Kupferstein und Anna Drah.
David Boder: Kupferstein?
Bertha Goldwasser: K u p f e rstein.
David Boder: Und Anna Drah?
Bertha Goldwasser: Anna Drah..
David Boder: Beide in Brooklyn?
Bertha Goldwasser: Beide in Brooklyn.
David Boder: Haben Sie auch die Telefon Nummern oder nur die Adressen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich habe die Adressen, nur die Adressen.
David Boder: Sie haben nur die Adressen.
Bertha Goldwasser: Nur die Adressen, ja. Und sie haben mir auch ein Affidavit geschickt, sie wollen auch, dass ich nach Amerika gehen soll.
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Aber leider, ich bin Polnische und die Quote für die Polen ist sehr „langweilig”, es kann vielleicht noch Jahre dauern.
David Boder: Ja, aber Sie waren Studentin hier?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, ich war Student.
David Boder: Sie waren Studentin?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Sie haben ein Diplom, dass sie vom Gymnasium graduiert haben?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, aber leider habe ich nichts, denn die Deutschen haben alles weggenommen und ich kann nicht ein Anderes bekommen.
David Boder: Was es in der Universität verschrieben, dass Sie dort waren?
Bertha Goldwasser: Es war, ja, es war da...
David Boder: Dann können Sie von der Universität eine Bescheinigung bekommen/
Bertha Goldwasser: Eine Bescheinigung kann ich ja auch bekommen, natürlich.
David Boder: Ja, das sollte ja genug sein.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, hm, sagen Sie mal hat die Marquis welche Gedichte, welche Lieder genannt?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja, wir haben sehr schöne Lieder geschaffen.
David Boder: Würden Sie vielleicht Eines für mich vorsingen?
Bertha Goldwasser: [lacht] Ne, das kann ich nicht [lacht wieder], ich hab keine Stimme [lacht].
David Boder: Sie brauchen das nur mit einer sehr kleinen Stimme..., Hauptsache, dass die Worte klar sind.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Nur summen, wie man sagt, probieren Sie es!
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich kann mich vielleicht nicht erinnern.
David Boder: Probieren Sie es, [unverständlich]
Bertha Goldwasser: In Französisch...meinen Sie?
David Boder: Ja. Kennen Sie keine jüdischen Lieder von den Lagern?
Bertha Goldwasser: Von den Lagern, ja.
David Boder: Ja. Wollen Sie mir diese vorsingen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Aber ich selber war nicht im Lager, Das sind irgendwelche Lieder, die welche...
David Boder: Ja. [unverständlich]
Bertha Goldwasser: [trägt ein Gedicht vor] Ravensbrück, Ravensbrück, Du bist [unverständlich] und vielleicht einmal werden wir über Freiheit sehen. Da würden wir mit dem Leben sagen, ja, Ravensbrück, du bist die Vergangenheit und Unglück und Unrast durch die Deutschen, durch die Nazis, dem jüdischen Volk. Wir sind ja Junge, die Leben im Herzen haben. Wir müssen zum Leben streben, aber die Deutschen haben das Streben mit schwarzer Tinte beschmiert. [Ende] Das sind noch mehr Worte, aber ich kann mich nicht erinnern.
David Boder: Bitte in Französisch.
Bertha Goldwasser: [spricht französisch]
Bertha Goldwasser: Da sind auch noch Wörter, an die kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie, was denken Sie, was Sie im Allgemeinen...was soll aus der Zukunft werden?
Bertha Goldwasser: Über die Zukunft? Ja, wenn man kann von der Zukunft sprechen, es ist sehr schön. Aber leider...ich kann mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, wie die Zukunft sein wird—ich auch nicht. Die Juden von Polen sind sehr unterdrückt. Die haben überhaupt keinen moralischen Instinkt, die haben überhaupt keine...keine Hoffnung zu leben. Die wollten nur wandern, die wollten laufen...nach Palästina lasst man sie leider nicht. England hat ihnen kein Zertifikat gegeben. Nach Amerika kann man nicht, man hat da für die Juden die Quote gesperrt. Also was sollen die Juden machen? Wohin sollen sie gehen? Sie haben keine Heimat. Sie wollen, aber können nicht eine zentrale Heimat haben. Sie wollen auch Palästiner sein, warum sollten wir die auch nicht sein? Also leider...kann ich, nein, kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen...wie so das Leben, das Problem vom jüdischen Leben allgemein auf der ganzen Welt wird sich, wird sich jetzt stellen die Frage. Wir stehen jetzt hier in ein Land für ein Weltkonferenz. Vielleicht wird man auch an uns sprechen. Das kann man nicht wissen. Der Jude im allgemeinen...ein europäischer Jude ist nicht sehr...ist nicht sehr, ist nicht sehr gesund vorläufig, weil moralisch—er hat kein Heimat. Er hat kein– wie man sagt im Jiddischen—kein Dach über dem Kopf. Und was kann der machen? Er ist gebrochen, keine Familie—von seiner Familie, von der schönsten Familie sind keine einzigen Menschen geblieben. Und von vielen hundert Millionen ist auch nicht Einer geblieben. Was kann man...
David Boder: Für welche Zeitung arbeiten Sie hier in Paris?
Bertha Goldwasser: Ich? Ich für die Neue Presse. Das ist eine Zeitung, welche den Arbeiter Klasse verklagt verständlich.
David Boder: Aha. Wie viele...wie viele jüdische Zeitungen gibt es in Paris?
Bertha Goldwasser: Es gibt viele jüdische Zeitungen in Paris, nicht alle...nicht alle sind einverständlich. Es gibt zionistische Zeitungen, es geben, hm, sozialistische, so genannte bundistische Zeitungen. Die sind die Ärgsten, weil sie haben eine schlechte Stellung gegen die, gegen die fortgeschrittene Arbeiterbewegung.
David Boder: Die bundistischen Zeitungen?
Bertha Goldwasser: Nehmen immer die...
David Boder: Ja?
Bertha Goldwasser: Die bundistischen Zeitungen nehmen immer die Gegenstelle gegen der Neuen Presse. Das ist ein Kampf zwischen zwei Arbeiterlager.
David Boder: Ist die bundistische Presse nicht eine sozialistische Presse, sondern eine sozial demokratische Presse?
Bertha Goldwasser: Eine Sozial-Demokratische sollte man so sagen, aber die [unverständlich] sind nicht so wie der Arbeiter will das haben.
David Boder: Sie denken das?
Bertha Goldwasser: Das sehe ich so.
David Boder: Das sehen Sie.
Bertha Goldwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Aber es gibt viele Leute, die diese Zeitung lesen,nicht wahr?
Bertha Goldwasser: Es gibt, aber sie haben nicht so einen Erfolg. Ich sage das jetzt nicht als Anhänger der Neuen Presse...
David Boder: Ja?
Bertha Goldwasser: . . . die welche einen gewaltig großen Erfolg hat. Wenn jemand kommt in eine jiddische Stube—in jeder jiddischen Familie in der Früh sehen sie eine jüdische Zeitung da. Das ist die Neue Presse—verständlich. Man sieht eine französische Zeitung, eine Arbeiter Zeitung auch oder auch eine Andere, aber der Jüd, aber der Jüd, der liest die...die Neue Presse.
David Boder: Die Neue Presse.
Bertha Goldwasser: Weil in der hat er...
David Boder: Ist die Neue Presse zionistisch?
Bertha Goldwasser: Nein, die Neue Presse ist nicht zionistisch. Die Neue Presse ist ein...nicht eine kommunistische, aber sie verteidigt den jüdischen Einwanderer, die verteidigt den jüdischen [unverständlich] Menschen, den Arbeiter, der im Haus arbeitet, der arbeitet in den Fabriken und den Intellektuellen, der...
David Boder: Was sagen die über Palästina?
Bertha Goldwasser: Über Palästina? Was sie sagen über Palästina?
David Boder: Ja.
Bertha Goldwasser: Sie haben sehr starke Meinungen über Palästina. Sie helfen auch in Palästina die Juden...den Juden, die gegen den...gegen den Bourgeois in die Lager, die welchen sich selbst eine Heimat schaffen, die wollen auch ein...
David Boder: Ich danke sehr, Frau Goldwasser, es war ein sehr gutes...[Tonband zu Ende oder abgerissen].